y dije una palabra palabra y luego dije
otra mi recuperación
me ha hecho cada vez más fuerte banksy
ahora las palabras salen mucho más
fáciles para mí aún tengo problemas para
hablar pero quiero que mi voz se escuche
eeuu necesita que todos hablemos when
you
incluso si tenemos que luchar para
encontrar las palabras
nosotros estamos en una doble vía
podemos dejar que esto continúe o
podemos actuar
podemos proteger a nuestras familias a
nuestro futuro podemos votar y dónde
podemos estar en el lado correcto de la
historia debemos elegir a joe by
linguaserve
él estuvo ahí para mi vida y él estará
ahí para ustedes también
únanse a nosotros en esta lucha voten
voten y voten
muchas gracias